welcome back to the show that will focus
on the genre of comedy
or romance definitely some drama some
action
for some horror is gonna be in there how
is this possible
well because we're hopping on the magic
bus it's gonna transport us all
back to high school lucky the golden age
of the high school flick began in
earnest with the 1980s
that's the first decade that
consistently churned out quality
academic related cinema that we still
fondly revisit today
and for our competitive purposes you
better have a full roster of all-time
greats because it's about deciding the
decade
of dewy decimal dominance that makes the
honor roll
apologies to the 1970s and particularly
the movie grease
we had to leave that era off our list
much to the chagrin of our producer alex
who still wears a t-bird's jacket to
work even in the heat of summer
when we're supposed to be on vacation
that's cool baby other hearts were
broken as well you see each decade we
are considering from the 1980s through
the 2010s
could have a maximum of six movies as
its representatives that means we get
the cream of the crop
but we also had to leave off some fan
favorites like license to drive pump up
the volume
freaky friday and boyhood and even i
mark ellis who lettered in basketball
cross country and baseball
suffered a fractured aorta as a result
of cuts being made
encino man which won paulie shore his
first of many oscars
will not be helping the 1990s today but
i promise when we do college movies
son-in-law is going to be there and when
we do war movies
in the army now we'll enlist and when we
do biosphere film
okay this is spiraling out of control
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score
round three iconic characters round four
memorable moments and then we'll do a
wild card round that i hope doesn't
involve trigonometry
for the most part sports related movies
will not be on the playing field today
we might do our own verses for that
so let's get hyped with some characters
we will be hearing from
jeff piccoli come on down stiffler put
down the beer and whatever else is in
that cup
juno grab your academy award and malcolm
jim diggy
prepare to make some bitcoin let's get
it on
so my student air student b my geek or
menace
you see us as you want to see us
sincerely yours
the breakfast club round one box office
i'm not a whiz when it comes to
demographics or which type of audience
is attracted to what kind of
entertainment
all i know about demos is that everyone
who watches this show regularly
has an iq of at least 150 and when it
comes to folks that want to go see high
school movies in theaters
you have the junior high high school
kids hoping to glean some insight into
how best conduct themselves in their
formative years
and adults looking for some rose or rose
tinted glasses with which to fondly walk
run or streak down memory lane life
moves pretty fast
you don't stop and look around once in a
while you could miss it
that's a pretty wide swath of human and
predictably every high school decade in
today's competitive video essay
boasts numerous hits that packed movie
theaters with butts
popcorn and probably snuck in boone's
farm
to be fair i guess i grade on a curve we
adjusted the following dollars and cents
into modern day bucks
and thanks to that math the 1980s show
up strong
two of our representatives from that era
grossed over 100 million dollars in
theaters
led by ferris bueller taking the day off
to the tune of 173 big ones
surely enough cheddar to buy cameron's
dad a new ride
all told our crop of 80s movies averaged
just a wolf man
chest hair under the magic line settling
at 95.3
million per flick bringing up the rear
but holding the boombox high
is say anything which still did a
respectable 46 million dollars
excellent all right this is great but
then the 90s came roaring into the
mainstream
and with them three movies that banked
over a hundred million dollars
led by the raunchy comedy despised by
pastry chefs everywhere
american pie that film which i can do an
entire ted talk about how without it we
don't get shit's creek grossed 184
million dollars domestically
not as gross but still profitable were
clueless
and she's all that both of whom
surpassed 100 million dollars
so it seems like the 1990s should be our
clubhouse leader right
as if randall pink floyd and his buds
and days confused
may have won our hearts on physical
media and cable but when richard
linklater's baby was unleashed upon the
world in 1993
it only made 18 million dollars in
ticket sales
all right all right just all right
mcconaughey creeping around high
schoolers drops the overall 1990s
average down to 92.3 million but the
best
was yet to come when the keg of the
1990s was tapped out
in came a new millennium that would
break records in the realm of high
school film profitability
the 2000s are by far the most dominant
decade at the movie theater
as their five films on our list averaged
131 million dollars at the box office
the flick that didn't register at the
multiplex more than made up for it on
disney channel views
because it's called high school musical
all in this together with the singing
basketball student athletes
our box office smashes like super bad
bring it on
and mean girls but the highest grossing
film of any we'll discuss today
is the oscar-winning juno the 2007
groundbreaking film beat out american
pie by
just a mill grossing 185 million dollars
and making diablo cody a household name
perhaps the biggest achievement of the
2000s was the lowest grosser we have
the 66 million dollar raking in napoleon
dynamite
66 million dollars for a quirky oddball
indy with no major stars
that alone is worth the vote for pedro
are you serious
i'm dead serious the 2010s saw a major
dip in dollar bills ranked
but not the quality of the film critical
darlings like dope and edge of 17
couldn't crack 20 million dollars on
minuscule marketing budgets
however the one flick from this decade
that did make over 100 million dollars
did so emphatically as
21 jump street giggled its way to the
tune of a 158 million dollar total haul
the 1980s proved high school folks are
here to stay in the 90s showed us that
every new generation is yearning for its
own box office juggernut
but the 2000s were by far the decade
where the bank vaults got the busiest
thanks to mclovin regina george and a
couple who didn't practice the
safest of lovemaking techniques the
2000s win round one
and take an early lead if we're going to
be the best we have to have the best
missy's the poo round two tomato
meter slash audience score we might as
well call this round and then there were
two
because the 1980s are providing stiff
competition to the revenge-minded 2010s
lackluster box office results be damned
the 2010s finally get to flex their
muscle in the round that asks the
eternal question of high school
does anyone like me i want to first be
fair to the 1990s and 2000s however
it's not critics and audiences we're
completely dismissing those films
in fact every decade represented today
boasts a fresh average on both the
tomato meter
and audience score metrics the 90s are
the slowest up the gym class rope in
both categories
as their 64 tomato meter average and 69
69 audience score indicate the 2000s
narrowly missed out on toppling the
1980s for second place on the tomato
meter
notching 77.3 to the 1980s
78.3 average the scoreboard isn't quite
as close in terms of audience score as
the 2000s dipped down to 75.8 percent
looking up in the 1980s and it's 81
for funsies the highest tomato meter of
any 1990s movie was
the deserving clueless at 82 percent
meanwhile juno once again helps out the
2000s with a high mark of 94
shockingly both those titles still fall
short of the best from the 1980s which
is remember that boombox movie how it
didn't dominate the box office
well apparently critics love peter
gabriel because say anything
is at 98 percent congrats to lloyd and
diane
but as far as scotty and boof go that
pains my inner child to say teen wolf
is rotten these waves are mine and it
weighs down the otherwise super fresh
decade of the 80s
the next lowest is fast times at
ridgemont high standing tall
at 76 percent maybe if director amy
heckerling could have talked van halen
into actually
doing the theme song for the movie like
she wanted it would have been even
taller in the tomato meter patch
uh but we still have cameron crowe hey
hey he wrote fast times
whose say anything remains unsurpassed
at 98 percent
uh-oh wait no it can't be good
god that's lady bird's music
[Music]
the 2017 awards contender is 99
on the tomato meter and the rest of that
decade helps get us all into an ivy
league school
three of our five selections from the
2010s boasts a tomato meter
of 90 or above the lowest rated film
is 21 jump street at a solid b average
of 84
all told this decade more than makes up
for the lackluster box office with a
91.6
tomato meter average lapping the field
by over 13 percentage points
it also eases out a close victory in
terms of audience score as it topples
the 1980s
81.6 percent to 81 percent
flat damn it teen wolf the 80s could
have had this one
is it too late to swap in back to the
future for
team i'm being told we can but we can
only use the eric stoltz footage what
kind of
deal is okay look all apologies to alex
p and the keaton family but the 2010s
have held off the 1980s
and get on the board it's one to one to
nothing to nothing
are you even up there round three iconic
characters
the 1980s have come so tantalizingly
close to winning a round in today's
knowledge bowl
could they finally score a point in the
iconic characters round
it's quite possible as no amount of
rotten is going to hold back
styles g white and his overstuffed
locker here
but the 1990s are also looking to get on
the scoreboard and they have paul rudd
kind of sort of making out with his
is she his cousin i never fully grasped
what was going on
we'll get there geez i'm bugging myself
fresh off its round two victory the
2010s are riding high into the round
that begs for character development
likely steering in the direction of
romance to all the boys i've loved
before is up for a challenge
as lara jean and peter make for arguably
the best couple in the entire decade
hi hi but malcolm jib and especially
kirsty clements diggy
are also irresistible as individuals and
who doesn't want easy a's rosemary and
dill to be their parents for a week
it is high school so we should probably
be on the lookout for cool teachers and
the iconic characters around aha
gotcha woody harrelson as mr broner
strikes the perfect notes in edge of 17.
his biting wit mixed with genuine
compassion for her students proves why
joan cusack got so excited hearing that
kind of same titled stevie nicks song in
the school of rock
which is not about high school kids so
we're safe
that richard linklater film did release
in the 2000s however
and that kids is what we call a smooth
transition
look i'd love to gush about popular
couples like juno and paulie
idiotic teams like seth evan and their
sexy hamburger friend
or notable standouts like napoleon but
if it's iconic characters you want only
one couple help launched a multi-film
franchise that now includes a meta
streaming show
high school musical i'll be honest i've
never seen
any of these movies and i didn't feel
compelled to do so for my prep in this
episode
i'm gonna mean something in the world of
theater so i'm just gonna say that zac
efron and vanessa hudgins are incredibly
talented
insanely likable and i still want ephron
in a game of one-on-one
to bar the title of another film from
this decade you me
on a playground game is the ones and
twos 211 may the best man win
and the second best dancer went all
right
said my piece that's nice i hope the
mean girls crew didn't hear me slight
then because you do not want to get on
the wrong side of regina george
not only did rachel mcadams and lindsay
lohan lead a dynamite high school
ensemble cast
mean young ladies also features miss
norberry
in a memorable performance by tina fey
we all saw our teachers out of school a
few times at a
grocery store or a mall or a blacksmith
shop
i grew up in colonial williamsburg it's
just as awkward as it is in this
note-perfect depiction here
but also shout out to mack and brendan
mcguffin juno
faced with an incredibly challenging
family dilemma they still found ways to
give us
heartfelt chuckles thanks to indelible
turns from jk simmons
and allison janney and i'm going to
punch that bleaker kid in the weiner
next time i see him
mack but now we turn the clock back a
bit more to the 1990s
if it's dumbfounded parents you want
witness american pie
i could remind you again of how great
eugene levy is in this series of movies
but i'll simply say
we'll just tell your mother you ate it
all
stifler's mom gives us all another
memory for the books as does overbearing
father larry miller in 10 things i hate
about you whoops
we can't take our eyes off of julia
styles and heath ledger's chemistry
either
but if we had to give this entire round
to one iconic character
it just might be cher alicia silverstone
was known for flipping us off in music
videos from aerosmith when clueless came
out
ever since her character's namesake has
become almost as iconic as
you know that other share no way
amy heckling got together quite the
ensemble cast for her seminal 1990s
movie
but that wasn't the first time she
pulled off such a feat in fact
this whole round could come down to
which gaggle of heckerling utes
is more memorable the questionable
student drivers in clueless
or the cross section of high school
pupils in 1982's
fast times at ridgemont high jeff
piccoli might be the first name you
think of when it comes to fast times
i mean the list of students who
successfully had a pizza delivered to
their desk
is very short jess piccoli zack morris
that's it that's the list but let us not
shortchange jennifer jason lee's stacy
or judge reinhold's brad i'm pretty sure
no one will ever shortchange anything to
do with phoebe cates's linda
and when you hear that car's tune does
anyone think of anything
else like including the surviving band
members do they think of anything else
rick ocasic forever mr hand is a
singular teaching presence in that film
but if it's authority you want to melon
camp against
look no further than the arch nemesis of
the breakfast club mr vernon
he was so hell-bent on disciplining
these teens that his reign of terror
somehow united the very different
backgrounds of the club
into one lovable iconic fist-pumping
force
another john hughes molly ringwald
collab gave us her samantha
in 16 candles but if we just needed one
more all-time great to give the 1980s
the win in this round over the likes of
mike dexter
torrance shipman and lady bird herself
we turn to the cold and clammy hands
of ferris bueller life does move fast
but not so quick that we'd forget the
harmonious trio of matthew broderick
mia sarah and alan ruck we also should
shout out ed rooney and his well-meaning
secretary
while we're here wow the 1980s won and i
didn't even have to do my deep dive into
what would have happened if teen wolf
played division one college ball
or why mick was 40 years old but still
in high school
ferris has saved the 1980s and that
decade gets its first victory today
[Applause]
round four memorable moments
oh yeah it's time to take all those
fancy characters we just gushed about
and put them into action
in the classroom and hallways sure but
also on the streets
maybe on the sports field and definitely
in the bedroom or in jim's case the
kitchen island
this round is all about the moments that
elevated these films from
run-of-the-mill coming-of-age flicks
and transformed them into the enduring
legacy of what it means
to be a kid in high school or in the
case of the 2000s
a cheerleader if you've ever been a
cheerleader i haven't or wore a cheer
uniform to class once i have
that's right you can probably guess the
lion's share of memorable moments in the
2000s decade
are thanks to cheer spirit and dance
routines
i tossed dance in there to make sure we
can include the awkward napoleon dance
sequence in here
it might be my favorite part of napoleon
dynamite
[Music]
bring it on succeeds in making us all
run the emotional gamut alongside our
protagonist
in the world of competitive cheer and
it's that denouement oh mickey that had
folks going cray-cray in the aisles as
the lights went back
up high school musical obviously has any
number of amazingly choreographed well
numbers and for viewers of a certain age
they still haven't forgotten the lasting
impact they've had
but this decade's top moments for me
come from super bad
and mean girls that is so fat who hasn't
felt the nerve-wracking rush of
buying a fake id or of katie's attempt
to fit in by learning the lingo like
fetch i'm still not sure if butter is in
fact a carb but i do know that if cops
ever allowed me to go nuts in a police
car
my song of choice would also be panama
it's a great driving tune
legal or otherwise
music would similarly play a huge role
in the best moments of the 2010s
from the lady bird crash into me usage
to the band are we oh in dope
and yes we can even count jonah hill's
slim shady moment in 21
jump street does it matter here that
they're just pretending
to be in high school i guess in the
movie they do act like ninth graders the
whole time anyway so we can allow it
[ __ ] you science
and while dope features a treasure trove
of iconic moments and
places shout out randy's donuts such as
student a or student b
or jacoby getting blackmailed or just
anything with william the drug dealer in
it
many of the greatest hits from the 2010s
owe a huge thank you
to the 1980s to all the boys i've loved
before features a
perfect reference to 16 candles and easy
a name drops numerous 1980 staples
and woodchuck takes it a step further to
recreate the say anything moment
so why do we keep looking back to a
bygone decade even as our whole future
particularly college is right in front
of us well there's a ton of great
memories from those movies
often imitated never duplicated is lloyd
in the famous boombox scene
i don't mean just paid homage and
subsequent films i'm talking real life
how many neighbors have had some idiot
boyfriend pull up to his ex's house and
hopes he can win her back if the right
song is loud enough
it's a great moment for moviegoers
possibly the most despised scene
in homeowner association history whether
or not your place has a pool
it's always a good idea to periodically
check to see if judge reinhold is
lurking around it
while i try to remain as classy and as
family friendly as i can
uh look who are we kidding the phoebe
kate's pull sequence is an all-timer
as is piccoli's surfer dream or really
any interaction between him
and mr hand danger is my business
i personally love the sports angles of
jefferson beating up on lincoln in fast
times
scottie howard turning into teen wolf in
the most intense
scrum in basketball history and ferris
catching a foul ball
at a cubs game on his day off bueller
plays out as one long great moment
from his opening monologue teaching a
generation of kids how to fake being
sick
up until the very end where he and then
later deadpool
encourage everyone to hit the road
choosing just one moment from that movie
is nearly impossible
so i'll just take the one with the most
people the parade
donkey shane to twist and shout it's
perfect and if you look closely in the
background
you can see the late great john schnepp
partying with all those other chicagoans
oh yeah cameron kick on the car is
pretty great too the detention dance in
the breakfast club or the heartfelt
final cake scene in 16 candles
john hughes gave us moments so lasting
we feel like we were those teens in
those movies
and those are in fact a living history
of what happened to us
i'm leaning towards giving this round to
the 1980s as well unless the 1990s can
somehow manufacture
an historic comeback for the ages
reaching home plate with a pie
is a good start but when i think of
american pie it's still that opening
sequence where jim is doing his best to
see through the squiggly lines of
blocked out adult cable channels
when his parents enter the room it's
perhaps the best tone setter for what
was to follow in high school movie
history
she's all that competes well for the
best musical moment from this decade
with its usage of fat boy slim
but 10 things i hate about you and can't
hardly wait make strong pushes
with can't take my eyes off you and
paradise city respectively
who would have thought those two tunes
would be uttered in the same sentence
ever
similarly to mr bueller clueless plays
out like a gigantic
memorable moment from the matchmaking of
teachers to the audience learning as if
and especially the driving scene getting
on a freeway in los angeles is
terrifying as an adult
try being a kid and taking that wrong
turn but it's dazed and confused that
features the most scenes that are
instantly recognizable and impactful the
intensity of being a young cheerleader
the pressure of being a football star
and the even more intense pressure of
being a pitcher on the mound
knowing you're going to get paddled as
soon as the game ends
music gives us a sense of mood
throughout from the legendary alice
cooper screaming the end of the school
year
to skynyrd's tuesdays gone signaling the
keg running out
to foghat's slow ride reminding us the
summer has just begun
can anyone hear the opening bass riff of
sweet emotion now and not think of cars
strutting around in the high school
parking lot and if this was strictly
around based on musical selection the
1990s might have the edge
but once again the 1980s have proven too
iconic to spot any other decade this
round
it certainly has a huge advantage
because it is the oldest and while most
of our lead characters in high school
films may not respect their elders
they all paid tribute to the
coming-of-age tales that came before
them
john hughes gave every decade to follow
a blueprint for how to make a high
school movie last
and amy heckerling kept her own roadmap
for multiple decades
but it all started in the 1980s plus the
constant struggle of styles to buy booze
and teen wolf
pre-dates superbad by a full 20 years
i don't even like fear never say
die surfing on a van counts as an iconic
moment and i guess it's one of the many
reasons the 80s are going to get another
point this round but kids please
do not surf on the top of moving vans at
home i'd rather you feel too fondly
about a dessert
than risk dying because a 35 year old
werewolf basketball movie told you to do
something the 1980s go up
two to one to one to nothing and the
1990s are the only round left
to not be on the board yet
kennedy kennedy kennedy kenneth
more so than the struggle of getting out
of winning of discovering who we truly
are
we love high school movies because they
make us feel young again
and the best part is we can watch them
with a beer and not worry about our
parents catching us
but if the lights flash twice that means
someone called the cops and everyone
scatter i don't care who you are
how old you are you could be 17 or 70.
the lights flash twice
you run like hell out the bathroom
window thanks for stumbling down memory
lane with me and congrats to the 1980s
for winning the coveted title
of best high school movie decade the
2010s were too concerned with real world
issues to care
and the 1990s just want this vid to end
but the 2000s
look out molly ringwald they lost
because of you
and they ain't happy about it i'm mark
ellis and you can catch me on social
media and let me know your take on the
best high school movie decade of all
time
i'm on twitter or facebook or instagram
or driving around the high school
parking lot
blasting jamiroquai still wearing my
high school varsity jacket
alright alright alright
[Music]
you